VIOLENCE BETWEEN PALESTINIAN
MILITANTS AND ISRAELI
SECURITY FORCES SURGED THROUGH
POINT NOT SENIORS.
A NUMBER OF DEAD AT BOTH SIDES
IS NOW AT THE HAS LEVEL SINCE
2015.
THE PALESTINIAN AUTHORITIES
WANING POWER IN THE WEST BANK
IS REFLECTED IN THESE INCREASE
VIOLENCE.
CNN'S SAM KILEY
GOT AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
ONE OF THE MOST ACTIVE MILITIA.
IT'S KNOWN AS THE JENIN
BRIGADES, HAVE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> FOR 20, YEARS THIS CAMP THE
JANINE REFUGE JEAN KEMP HAS
BEEN A HOT ONE --
DOZEN IN THE LOCATION OF THE
PLANNING OF ATTACKS OF
CIVILIANS INSIDE ISRAEL ITSELF.
BUT NOW THERE IS A STEP CHANGE
IN THE ATMOSPHERE HERE.
AS OF SOMETHING MUCH MORE
VIOLENT IS TO COME.
AND I MEANT TO FIND OUT WHY AT
A MEETING WITH MILITANTS THAT
ARE THE TOP OF ISRAEL'S MOST
WANTED LIST.
WE MEET IN A SHRINE TO THE
PALESTINIANS WHO HAVE KILLED
FIGHTING ISRAEL.
FOR ISRAELIS, THIS MEMORIALIZES
MURDER.
THESE MEN ARE BEING HUNTED,
THEY SAY, BECAUSE THEIR ARMS
AND THEY ARE PLOTTING ATTACKS
AGAINST ISRAEL.
FOR MILITANTS, AND 12-YEAR-OLD
BOY WERE KADE IN THIS RAID AT
THE END OF SEPTEMBER.
[NOISE] THIS MAN SAYS HE
SURVIVED AN ISRAELI RAID ON
JANINE, ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
HIS COMRADE WAS KILLED.
[NOISE] LIKE HIM THESE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE JANINE RUGGED.
A MILITANT GROUP, NOW POSING A
DANGER TO THE PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITY, AS WELL AS TO
ISRAEL.
IT'S UNHEARD OF, LOW TO BREAK
COVER FOR AN INTERVIEW, MUCH
LESS TO COMMIT WHERE THEY GOT
THEIR.
GROUNDS YEARS AGO THEY HAD
AK-47S, NOW THEY HAVE M16S,
THIS ONE EVEN HAS HEBREW
WRITTEN ON, IT WAS A STOLEN
FROM THE ISRAELIS?
>> [INTERPRETER]
THEY SALUTE ON THE BLACK
MARKETS.
OUR RESISTANCE FIGHTERS BY
THESE WEAPONS WITH THEIR OWN
SALARIES AND MONEY.
>> A 2020 REPORT FROM ISRAEL'S
LEGISLATOR FOUND THAT SOME
400,000 LEAD ILLEGAL A WEAPONS
WHERE IN ISRAEL.
MANY OF THEM STOLEN FROM THE
ISRAELI DEFENSE FORCES.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOUR RULES AND
ENGAGEMENT?
WHAT ARE THE MORAL DECISIONS
THAT YOU TAKE ABOUT WHO YOU DO,
AND WE DO NOT ATTACK?
>> [INTERPRETER]
WE ARE THE RESISTANCE, WE
DEFEND OUR PEOPLE AND SACRED,
PLACES WE DON'T ATTACK.
[NOISE] >> THIS HAS BEEN NEEDED
THIS YEAR FOR PALESTINIANS AND
IRANIAN SINCE 2015.
AT LEAST 2300 PALESTINIANS HAVE
BEEN KILLED OUTSIDE OF GAZA.
GUNMAN FROM JIM IN HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN BUT THESE TWO MAJOR
ATROCITIES WHICH EIGHT PEOPLE
WERE SHOT DEAD EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
THE EXPANSION OF ISRAELI JEWISH
SETTLEMENTS ON THE WEST BANK,
AND THE DWINDLING FATE OF THE
PALESTINIAN STATE CAN EVER
EMERGE OF THE ISRAELI 55 YEARS
OF --
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THIS JEANINE RUGGED ARE
FIERCELY OPPOSED TO THE VERY
EXISTENCE OF ISRAEL, AND
DESPISE THE RULING PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITY FOR COOPERATING WITH
THE JEWISH STATE.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THIS IS A
COMPLETELY HOPELESS FIGHT THAT
YOU ARE FIGHTING, BECAUSE THE
ISRAELIS I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
DEFEAT THEM.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA GO ANYWHERE.
AND THEY HAVE THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY SUPPORTING.
THEM AT THE SAME TIME, THERE IS
SUPPORT FOR THE IDEA OF A
TWO-STATE SOLUTION FOR THE
PALESTINIANS, FOR AN
INDEPENDENT PALESTINIAN STATE.
IS THIS KIND OF A DEATH GRIP
THAT YOU'RE IN?
NO >> [INTERPRETER]
WE ALWAYS AIM FOR VICTORY NOT.
>> TO --
THERE ARE EXTENSIVE MEETINGS
WITH THE RESISTANCE IN GAZA AND
THE WEST BANK, AND WITH OUR
BROTHERS ABROAD [INAUDIBLE]
>> MANY FIGHTERS IN THIS GROUP
ARE FROM THE PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITIES OWN SECURITY
FORCES.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO STOP ATTACK
HENRY ISRAEL.
--
IT WOULD BE THE PALESTINIAN
LEADERSHIP THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST TO BURN.
>> SAM KILEY, BACK FROM
ASSIGNMENT AND HE IS IN LONDON
AND JOINS US NOW.
YOU DESCRIBE THE ATMOSPHERE IN
JANINE, AS HAVING CHANGED SOME,
AND YOU CHAT TO PALESTINIAN
RESISTANCE, WHERE IS THIS
HEADED?
>> WELL, SINCE I RECORDED THAT
REPORT.
THERE HAS BEEN AT LEAST ONE
MAJOR ISRAELI OPERATION INSIDE
GINNI, AND WE UNDERSTOOD TWO
PALESTINIANS WERE KILLED, AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
OPERATIONS ALSO IN --
THESE OPERATIONS THE ISRAELIS
SAY ARE AGAINST THESE MILITANT
GROUPS.
THEY ARE OUTSIDE, EVEN, OF THE
PURVIEW AND CAN ROLL, GROUP
SLICK THE JENIN GROUP THAT IS
CAUSING CONCERN FOR THE ISRAELI
DEFENSE FORCES.
THERE'S AN IDEA THAT THEY ARE
SEEING A PAGEANT IN THE EYE AND
NORTH --
IT'S A SIMILAR PATTERN THAT
I'VE SEEN RUN UP, SOME 22 YEARS
AGO WHERE YOU HAVE HAD
GRASSROOTS GROUP EXPRESSING
FRUSTRATION AS MUCH, ALMOST,
AGAINST THE PALESTINIAN
LEADERSHIP, THE OFFICIAL
LEADERSHIP, AS AGAINST THE
ISRAELIS.
OF COURSE, WITH THE ISRAELIS
WHO WOULD BE TARGETED IN THE
FIRST INSTANCE OF --
BUT ULTIMATELY A GREAT DEAL OF
FRUSTRATION THERE AND THE ISSUE
WILL BE CAN THE PALESTINIAN
LEADERSHIP CONTROL ITS EARLY
DAYS.
THE ISRAELIS HAVE LAUNCHED A
SIGNIFICANT OPERATION OF WHAT
THEY SAY, A PINPOINT OPERATION,
TO TRY TO SNUFF OUT THESE ARMED
OPPOSITION GROUPS BEFORE IT
GROWS TOO FAR.
BEFORE THAT CONGREGATION THAT
THE COMMANDER THERE WAS WARNING
MAY BE COMING.
>> YEAH.
YOU MENTIONED THE EXPANSION OF
WEST BANK SETTLEMENTS, THE
DISILLUSIONMENT OF PALESTINIAN
AUTHORITIES.
AS SUGARS FOR THIS RECENT
VIOLENCE AMONGST SOME OF THE
PALESTINIANS.
DO THEY, ENGINEERING, HOLD OUT
ANY HOPE THAT PALESTINIANS CAN
EMERGE AT THIS POINT?
>> JANINE IS A PRETTY RADICAL
CAMP.
IT WAS VERY ACTIVE IN THE --
IT WAS THE SCENE A VERY, VERY
VIOLENT CLASHES BACK THEN WITH
NUMEROUS DEAD ON BOTH SIDES.
PARTICULARLY IN 2002.
I THINK THAT IT IS A HOTBED OF
RESISTANCE IN A MUCH WIDER
SENSE.
MANY PEOPLE THERE, CERTAINLY
THE MILITANTS THERE DO NOT
BELIEVE IN HIS TO TWO STATE
SOLUTION, THEY DO NOT BELIEVE
IN THE RIGHT OF THE JEWISH
STATE TO EXIST.
THAT PRESENTS ISRAEL WITH AN
ENDURING PROBLEM, PARTICULAR ON
THE RIGHT --
WHEN YOU HEAR THAT KIND OF
COMMENT, PEOPLE GET VERY
ANXIOUS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT A
VIABLE PALESTINIAN STATE WOULD
BE AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
ISRAEL.
IF THAT CAN'T BE OVERCOME, THEN
ULTIMATELY THE SUBTLE MEANT
PROJECT AND THE CONTINUED
PERPETUATION OF THIS OCCUPATION,
AND AREAS ACROSS THE WEST RANK,
PERPETUATED AND THAT WOULD
INEVITABLY A PUSHBACK FROM MORE
RADHIKA GROUPS IN THE
PALESTINIAN COMMUNITY.
ON TOP OF, THAT THERE IS THE
ROLE OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, THE EUROPEAN UNION
SPENDING SOME 450 BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR JUST ON THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY TRYING TO
TIE IT ALTOGETHER, KEEP IT
GOING EFFECTIVELY.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
SAM, THANK YOU.
A REMINDER OF, COURSE ISRAELIS
ARE GOING TO THE POLLS AGAIN
NEXT WEEK.
DO YOU KEEP AN EYE ON OUR NEWS
LETTER.
MEANWHILE, IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
REGION ON THE REGION, FROM THE
REGION, AN INSIDE LOOK AT THE
BIGGER STORIES AND TRENDS IN
THIS REGION AND WHAT THEY MEAN
FOR YOUR WORLD WHEREVER YOU ARE
WATCHING.
CNN.COM, SLASH MIDDLE EAST NEWS
LETTER IS HOW YOU CAN SIGN UP
TO THAT.